[Música]
estoy sabía que el 90% de la información
que hay en internet es falsa
y eso no es cierto
s
[Música]
es una de las agencias
para
muchísimas
de lo que nosotros queramos utilizar
a los niños a la escuela y queríamos una
caricatura donde se llama la pista
yo
y es lo mejor
la producción de entonces llamas al
momento en el que quiere este
funcionario
en agencias de inteligencia social es
combinado
estos procesados entenderlos y utilizar
las redes sociales que se llaman
segmentación
[Música]
todas y todos
ellos
[Música]
y sobre todo
filtros
qué filtro donde que pasa una disolución
al estar en internet
inocentemente comparte
pero cuando aumenta la cuenta en la
parte de atrás
tránsito
y bueno
bueno
y después no será nada
yo que mi ciencia
puede tener un arma y si es una buena
propuesta
[Música]
me mandó al campo donde
empezando con su hijo
si todos
pero qué pasó con los que abiertamente
en facebook
de esos mensajes y diferentes ojos
el texto lo hizo presidente ante los
ojos bonitos del mundo
os quiero invitar a que antes de
compartir una noticia incluso
o no
reflejas los niños que están en
comunicación
es decir controlar la delincuencia
él es un tirano
si yo estoy del lado que voy a leer
cuando ustedes hicieron
[Música]
porque es una decisión
si yo trato con números con estadísticas
no ha funcionado
aunque mejor
[Música]
todas las versiones que ustedes están
tomando
están siendo solamente y descaradamente
manipuladas a la agencia estudiantes
o no
de lo que hice en cinco diferentes
portales
a todos
[Aplausos]
[Música]